Tim being here with you it's the
greatest feeling I've had in a really
long time Friday Night Lights where
would Tyra and Tim today well here's the
thing I have a pitch I think it would be
great to restart the show but instead of
you know Tami Taylor and Coach Taylor
we are the new Tami and coach I'm
thinking more along the lines of um this
is tea I can see that it's gonna be a
little bit more like crazy because he's
still gonna be Tim Riggins and I'm still
gonna be Tyra Collette married mm-hmm
I'm the counselor he's a football coach
still a little bit of an alcoholic how
many kids do Tyra and him have Oh too
many obviously they'd have to be
football yes what would it take to get
that to happen I mean have you been in
touch with any of the writers have you
talked to Taylor kid call Pete Berg Pete
Berg yes this is what we're doing I had
dreams too
adrianne palicki is ready for a Friday
Night Lights spin-off but right now she
stars the new rom-com baby baby baby and
she's filming her upcoming Seth
MacFarlane series Orvil it's a comedy
it's set in space um it's actually it's
a dramedy you have a lot of heart in the
show it's it's unlike anything I think
he's ever written um it has a Star Trek
aspect to it but it's fun and you have
these these two characters who are exes
who are forced to work together on a
spaceship you have a little bit of that
Ross and Rachel thing happening huh so
what's that like to kind of spar with
him in that way oh it's fun yeah it's
fun I love me laughs yes all the time
yeah and Angry all the things so it
works up perfectly
Adrian also got candid about her 2011 a
Wonder Woman series that never aired do
you feel like it was before its time
I absolutely think it was two years
early my biggest dream ever was to get
paid to wear that costume it was
phenomenal it was devastating when it
didn't go now obviously
it's worked itself out but at the time
it was devastating
have you seen gal gadot's Wonder Woman I
have not and it's not out of any
bitterness for anything like that I just
haven't would you ever want to get back
into the comic world absolutely I mean I
that world is my world I want to play
rogue so emotional she couldn't kiss you
know she couldn't touch it was just so
sexy
[Music]
you